foreign
[Music]
yesterday but traditionally the way to
do this was do a cinema movie and that
seems to be what I was going to thinking
about let's kicked out the franchise
with a cinema movie because I think
Jennifer sulky thinks that's still the
way things work
since streaming services have come along
though and I honestly think things have
changed do you do we even think
they need to kick-start this with a
cinema movie
or does it
I was in some ways is it a waste of time
and money
I've always been of the opinion that you
don't need to have a cinema movie you
could just go straight in with a series
I mean a movie is great and I'll be
happy if there was one and I'd still
watch it
but
I've always said at a series you can do
so much more and you can explain so much
more you could do like a slow burn
series
it doesn't have to explain everything
all in within an hour and a half you
could do things that explain little bits
here little bits there and have an
overarching story and that's I think for
me personally that's always a lot more
satisfying than watching a movie
yeah because you have to wait a week for
one you have to wait a week to see
what's going to happen next
um you might have
it might only be 10 or 12 episodes but
that's 12 hours worth of story compared
to one and a half hours and I think
that's the main thing
that I prefer you just get more
from it
and you look at things like stranger
things
but that did really well I'm not saying
stargate's gonna do as well as as what
stranger things does but people will
talk about new series when they come out
and more people will come in and I think
people talk about series more than they
do movies and don't get they showed
strange things the last series in
cinemas
so the last couple of episodes in over
here they didn't know if they did in the
US or not but over here they showed a
few of them the day before in the cinema
because they were so popular and it
worked
um
going on from that Harris though right
so nowadays in particular and I think on
some films over a few years I always
think about think about
um Starship Troopers there was no decent
actors in that you could actually argue
that that the main actor whose name I
can't remember now
anyway can't act at all he is so wooden
and it is painful to watch him
um only
um the one guy and it was actually good
he's an awesome name I can't remember
anyway
um
there's no dish Net in that they put all
of the money on the screen and made of
just a phenomenal movie
could they just do that with Stargate
does it matter I I know and I would
argue that that's more true today that
you don't need big stars you don't need
a Jason Momoa in the movie for it to
succeed you just need it to excite fans
does it matter
about the actors and whether they're TV
actors or not or known or whatever as
much anymore as it used to yeah
he's God is the worst actor
I was looking up I was like well Neil
Patrick Harris Clancy Brown everybody
else is great It's gotta be him uh it's
awful
you
you might have to give me the first part
of that question again but the the
second part least
I I
I think it does matter if they're TV
actors or or film actors just because of
the way they're trained if they're
trained both ways that's fine and they
are similar enough particularly in how
TV's handled nowadays it's a lot more
film-like so I think that might help to
that degree
but I still think they need film actors
I I it's just it's a very different
world and
yeah they're Bridging the Gap there but
I I would think they still need a film
actor over a TV actor I don't think they
should rely on TV actors or people that
have
specified in TV over decades to lead a
new film especially in a different era
of film this is I just wonder if the
um the lines of blurred nowadays between
the two and I think it goes both ways
film actors started appearing streaming
services but I think it's it's blurred
both ways I don't think you need
those big actors anymore I think the
fact that it's a Stargate movie will
generate enough interest anyway they
don't need the Jason Momoa thing to
attract attention it's a Stargate movie
it will get attention
um it Nostalgia is a big thing and if
they bring a couple of the actors back
but also I'd quite like to be this this
sin if they're gonna do a cinematic
movie for me I like the Jason Momoa idea
because I love Jason Momoa for one
um but it would have to be a standalone
movie because they're not going to get
Jason Momoa in the series chances are
they might get him to do the odd episode
maybe but chances are he's not I'd like
the movie to be connected to the series
I don't want it to be constructed
so in that case you've got to have
actors that are willing to do the movie
but then do the series as well
I that would be that would be the way I
want to do this and again you don't have
to explain everything in the movie
but I want it to lead into the series
you know
um yeah whatever
and wouldn't that make
more sense yeah Denise Richards was
terrible in that as well
[Music]
um I think it makes perfect sense
and there's a there's a lot to be said
for that but then if you're gonna do a
film with
I just I just it has to be actually I
think the film would have to be 10 times
as good as it would have to be if it was
a Ronan decks even oriented film or any
of the other characters because there
would be that Nostalgia bit if you're
just bringing the other characters back
as
pure Nostalgia and and you're relying on
new actors whether they're TV actors
film actors or whatever that's putting a
lot on these new guys back and a lot on
these new guys plate which which is good
they need to do that
but that so that's a lot because then
the other actors the old actors would
literally of course they might have
story points but it would feel like it
would just be for Nostalgia at that
point
um we we need a little something more
sound I think for him and
have it and that that's the thing Momoa
is
it's easy to go back to him partially
because he's not an Oscar actor he's he
literally in all of his movies he's more
of a TV actor than he is
a film actor still which plays too good
and bad traits of them and I just feel
like that fits more it's our
expectations wouldn't feel as high going
in if it weren't people that we knew
but going out our expectation or while
we were sitting there I think our
expectations would be 10 times as high
because it has to be something to draw
people in at that point and it's not
using anything to draw people in besides
Nostalgia I guess
[Music]